much of the Republican Presidential
feels spent this weekend in Iowa they're
trying to win over voters in the first
caucus State now it was an opportunity
to distinguish themselves from the front
runner that would be former president
Donald Trump Chief election and campaign
correspondent that's Robert Costas
watching it all in the front row Bob
good morning to you A lot of people
trying to make a good impression this
weekend they certainly are good morning
Gail this annual roast and ride
fundraiser hosted by Senator Joni earns
has become an important marker at the
beginning of Iowa's political calendar
and many contenders did show up shaking
hands posing for selfies and seeking a
breakthrough
Iowa was full of motorcycles barbecue
and Republican politics how's the great
state of Iowa
eight GOP hopefuls were on hand but
missing was front-runner former
president Donald Trump who was in the
Hawkeye State last week
Iowa's Republican Governor Kim Reynolds
was there Saturday and responded to
Trump's absence I think it was a missed
opportunity we had nearly a thousand
Iowans that were at the State
Fairgrounds to listen to the candidates
that are vying to be the president of
the United States President Biden and
the Democrats remained the main target
for the GOP field Joe Biden's policy are
the wrong direction for America taking
aim at their handling of the economy the
military transgender rights education
immigration and abortion you can't do
any of any of it if you don't win while
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis who's
running second in the polls continued to
take veiled swipes at Trump there is no
substitute for victory and we need to
dispense with the culture of losing that
is beset the Republican party in recent
years Ambassador Nikki Haley on Sunday
night former South Carolina Governor
Nikki Haley used a CNN Town Hall in Iowa
to make her case it is time for a new
generational leader it is time for us to
leave the baggage of the past the
negativity to the past and start
thinking of our families and this week
former vice president Mike Pence hopes
to drive up his chances and I don't have
anything to announce today but I can
tell you
when I got time to announce come this
Wednesday I'm announcing in Iowa
also expected to get in the race this
week former New Jersey Governor Chris
Christie who is set to announce on
Tuesday in New Hampshire and North
Dakota governor Doug burgum on Wednesday
all ahead of that first Republican
primary debate in August Gail
yeah but Donald Trump just says bring it
on Bob before you go word on the street
is there could be some significant
updates in the special counsel's
investigation into Trump's handling of
the classified documents what are you
hearing about that what do you know
that's right this special counsel he
still looms over the presidential race
with Trump's competitors watching
developments closely and sources with
knowledge of the investigation believe a
charging decision in this document's
case led by special counsel Jack Smith
is imminent and could be coming in the
next few weeks two sources also tell CBS
news that Trump's legal team could meet
with Justice Department officials this
week regarding the document's case the
special counsel's office has declined to
comment and Trump's lawyers were
unavailable to comment Gail
all right we're all still watching thank
you very much Bob Costas